Hello if in the next
In the year you will take a high school diploma in Polish
in the new formula
be sure to watch this video
because today I will give you 4 tips
about writing an argumentative essay
in the form of dissertation
You can also use it during the exam.
sample my previous material
in which I gave advice
What can
apply when writing a trial matura exam in December
you liked it so much
thank you for all the likes
I decided to write part 2.
about the dissertation
1.
part I gave directions
Reading comprehension and test
historyczno-literackiego
I encourage you to watch this video I will add
that this and other
materials prepares based and information
found on the site cke
as well as textbooks
repetitions and so on publishing operon
because the test matura
It is prepared by experts
from this publishing house
But back to the main topic
I give advice
which is worth using when writing a dissertation
After 1.
Before you start writing,
prepare an outline
it's not about that
to be very complicated
expanded but it is crucial
to write down or write down readings and contexts
to which you will refer
to later formulate the thesis on
all works
Give an example topic
sounds like a difficult experience
and their diverse impact on human life
Works you can relate to
Konrad valenrot
Borowski's stories
another world of Georgian kerling and kordian
When it comes to contexts
I would refer to the Bible and the book of Job.
and to the mythology and history of the Odysseus
only After selecting works and contexts
you can put a thesis an example thesis could sound
Difficult life experiences
They affect in various ways the
human life
They can degrade the individual.
How and make
that man will strengthen and you will revise your worldview
2.
formulating the thesis
Use the keywords used in the topic
Do not use synonyms for keywords
because from my experience it appears
Sometimes students think
that a word is close
used in the question.
and it is not so
If you do not use keywords
Work can be judged worse
Or in extreme cases,
it can even go wrong.
because it will not match the theme
example the theme of the essay is loneliness
Opportunity or Limitation
the student wanted to enter some other word and wrote
loneliness can be an opportunity
but also loss
Poorly put thesis is unfortunately a big mistake
So beware of these types of mistakes
It is also worth learning how to formulate a thesis
matching a specific type of topic
Because not all are the same
in 1 of the next videos
I will tell you about the types of essay topics
if you want to know more
I encourage you to follow the profile
Third,
remember
Context is not a digression
Contexts are usually references to other children.
as a reminder
types of context I give in the description of the film
They are also listed here
behind me
in the publisher's repetitory the operon is written
The correct context should be
build arguments
An example of a new argument
The context is unclear.
Related 1 sentence
which can be entered at any time
The context should consist of a few sentences.
It can be completed with a proposal
As an argument related to reading
If you are interested in film
In which I will discuss in detail
How to correctly introduce
Contexts on Examples
write a comment
the last 4th tip
remember that the introduction is not just a thesis
It should encourage you to read
Whole work
I often tell my students.
that the original introduction will distinguish the work from others
The teacher may later
evaluate working out more gently
This is a psychological effect.
which, however,
is worth using
What elements can you introduce
to make your introduction more interesting
For example,
you can define words.
Key to the topic
and consider different ways of understanding these concepts
you can also refer to the era and describe
How the understanding of a
Issues in subsequent periods
These are just suggestions
and all the tips for today
if you have any questions or want to
to raise a specific topic yy in the next video
I encourage you to comment